non mi dire che era stato qualcosa ma
non certo la paura dice benvenuti sony
d'affari
oggi nuovo video speciale quello che
stiamo alta da parti a cavallino una
ludoteca parco giochi è enorme si sono
due sale e giganti pratica praticamente
la challenge sarà di trovare gli
ingredienti di trovare gli ingredienti
slime nascosti qua in questa ludoteca
enorme per ora siamo in questa sala
gigante che da da parti 2.0 poi ci
sposteremo anche nell'altra sala da da
parti sempre che la stata enorme un
tacco di cosa
non so che un bel mi piace se volete una
seconda parte trova gli ingredienti slam
nascosti al parco giochi minuto teca e
iniziamo subito vitale racconterà gli
ingredienti slime qua nella sala è data
2.0
io dovrò stare in un angolino tipo
magari mi nascondo in quella casetta
laggiù per non vedere dove vitale ha
nascosto gli ingredienti alla fine
dovrete votare chi vince in base alla
bellezza dello slam
ringraziamo tantissimo data parti per
averci ospitato oggi qui nella sua
ludoteca fantastica norme e iniziamo
subito la salle nasconderti della porta
finestra chiusa la finestra e non
sbirciare bra oggi da una parte adesso
facciamo con questi mattoni facciamo
chiediamo sono bellissimi ti diamo noi
moriamo moriamo
che bello nascondiamo qualcosa qui
ricalcolato non ascoltiamo sotto lo
scivolo
o questa bella parente che lo vado a
nascondere qui si confonde bene bluecall
blu
amo le bustine con le palline qua dietro
ne abbiamo ricevuto nell'angolino
e poi ho preso preso i glitter thirty
perani da dietro e poi in questo
colorante invece li mettiamo
qui sulla stanza del libretto iniziare
hai nascosto qualcosa alla sovra sei
sicura arrivi e non lo so e l'aveva
nascosta bene lì c'è una cosa dai
dammela dardengo io ho deciso di entrare
solo così possiamo sin qui la vita da
vicino attento potrebbe rimanere
vito non cadere secondo me è possibile
che lei nascosti guarda allora provo
scendere d'acqua
vediamo se evitare il nascosto colpi tra
si vede tutto dalle auto che fai
ho controllato come stai compilato non
mi dire che in tutto quel che sa fare un
certo da un indizio possibile trovarle
qui a fare qualche pallina esistono ti
do di indizio o nascosto bento e
ingredienti anzi nelle palline
però però non è in questo playground che
lo nascosta e leon nascosta in un altro
playground 4 aiuta mi dirai tirai non
così forte un'arancia è un arancino ci
sono gli spike dobbiamo stare attenti
arrivo d'acqua posso entrare vista
ed acqua di inserire la nostra parte ma
io voglio ripartita farmer market aiuta
no devo fare tutto il giro e si aspetta
mi è venuta l'idea
aspettiamo qual è questa idea come ho
fatto io per nasconderla o anche la
soluzione per lenti ora cosa dovrò
trovare in mezzo a queste palline queste
mete politici sono qui magari sta sotto
notte mi è venuta l'idea posso provare a
nuotare nelle palline ottima soluzione
mi riposo un pochino ci vediamo noi
rimango qua ho scoperto che le palline
sono più comode del materasso del letto
di ritrovare gli ingredienti ho capito
groli troverò mai
e va bene che va rimesso tu adesso ora
sempre qui ma era sempre lì con voi cosa
trovavo la paletta che volendo anche a
sapori manca solamente la ciotola e la
collana forse sopra questo ponte porterò
a creare con motivo per in piedi ma
realtà solo perché siamo pazzi di vita
lei non riesce a salire in alto lazio
c'erano le palline con lo scivolone
benissimo di palline ciao guarda io in
quello giallo bravi palline lì
e proprio enorme questo posto con le
palline però sono tutte rosa viola che
bene combattimento mi metto delle altre
cose se vai sotto il tavolo line è anche
visto sotto il naso dove non ci si
accorge per apprendere parole il
colorante limiti allora devo fare il
simbolo uscire da qua lità ancora padre
riguarda soprattutto il gioco di
supermario non proibito gioco ci sono
tutti gli ostacoli qua divertente lo
scivolo voleva dire qui che bella forse
si fa prima sentendo dal dott certo che
sì ma io l'ho già trovato un altro
ridendo mi qua
e uno no allora noi siamo appena usciti
d'acqua guardate quante grande invece
preparava molla più
ora ho visto il colorante che era
proprio qua e vivano trovato ci manca
adesso sono la ciotola forse qua in
questo campetto da calcio
ma l'aspetto e perché hai indovinato
viviamo seguita l'anno scorso qualcosa
ancora uno spicchio vero mostrare io
controllato bene benissimo e si è
nascosto al buio tre i clienti come
decorazione ha nascosto delle palline
rosse dove sono le palline rosse palline
rosse
sai che ti dico secondo me le palline
rosse non si stanno bene questa
difficilissima da nascondere cioè nel
senso la voglio far diventare difficile
per anita devo nasconderlo in un posto
dove ci vorrà tantissimo tempo per
arrivare e che sarà super complicata
siccome arida
guardiamo fifona lancio nero al centro
di questo tipo
e qui non si noterà nemmeno sono
l'ingiusto pipistrello ci fai qua
pensavo di aver trovato tutti gli
ingredienti ma manca la colle serra
all'albert park
io mi sto riposando sono stato se tu sei
qui vuol dire che hai nascosto qualcosa
qua no il ponte quando mi fido di vitale
ok stiamo continuando a salire ora siamo
al terzo piano
vi ricordate cos'era il ponte rosa e con
punto in cui non sono andata e proprio
qua il tunnel non te lo dico ho
l'impressione che vitale abbia nascosto
qualcosa qua nel tuo me lo sapevo
guardate
c'è apposta per farne passare il turno
sì ce l'ho fatta però posso andare
quando stai tra l'altro stato bravo
insomma con rosa ma non ho messo nessun
ingrediente strano ma che fai
i muscoli ma smettila con gli altri due
ingredienti mi arrendo non bastano qui
dove sto ok allora un ingrediente una
decorazione era proprio qui non ho
peccato questi li avrei voluti da
ricorrenti mormora vieta le usi perché
non hai trovato una decorazione del tuo
colore preferito quindi verde che in di
dover ed il verde
vittima lina scotto degli enti di questi
colori qui così si mimetizzavano e non
li trovavo dove realizzare invece no e
quindi non lo mettono questi sono gli
ingredienti che anita ha trovato che ci
sono quelli che anita non ha trovato le
palline il glitter verte in glitter rosa
oggi sono state decorazioni davvero
questo colore è stato identico colore è
il viatico si guarda hanno forse un
pochino più chiesto allora andiamo a
mettere il bicarbonato poco poco poco
fox ne è caduto un po troppo
[Musica]
e come non poteva mancare il verde
seppure sulla sedia verde uno dei
bisogni inutili mischiare ma non è
giusto non li aveva trovati quelli non
puoi mettere di nuovo per una condizione
del werder ci deve essere comunque bene
devo dire che non è male però almeno c'è
qualcosa di brillantinato in almeno c'è
un pochettino più di carattere questo
slime orribile ma neve e bellissima rosa
lunga
andiamo ad attivarlo devo ripeterlo
guarda e clive news live
allora è uscito un rosa un po più scuro
è ancora un po pc cosa comunque sito un
rosa un po più scuro un rosa
evidenziatore con i glitter verdi
purtroppo è vitale io andrei a
nascondere gli ingredienti slime
nell'altra sala di dada parti capitale
dovrà provarli città siamo nell'altra
sala di data parti cordate che grande
anche quasi sono un pacco di cose quindi
io dovrò nascondere gli ingredienti
staiano vitale già qualche idea buffet
come scritto ecco si trova qua ok italia
ci ha più carte sicuramente quindi
allora per gli altri ingredienti non pt
rom e firmerò dove li metto così anche
voi dovrete trovarvi assieme a vitale
siete fronti 321 tutti gli enti
vediamo se ci metterà più o meno tempo è
facile vedo qualcosa o hai già trovato
un ingrediente
a noi piace un cagnolone un pagliaccio
una zucca in zucca
ho trovato il bicarbonato ci diamo
dentro la bazzarra tratta di una pallina
seguita nel range extender mostrava un
po dentro aiuto quindi per lei trovato
il bicarbonato lasciato dentro
freddo e risultava preso
ma chi sono gli altri tipi di strasicura
che stanno modello si terranno degli
altri inoltre ha detto andiamo a vedere
cosa c'è e cosa qua dentro c'è qualcosa
da parte di questa tematica aiuta una
spesa e facendo la colla importante mi
sembra strano che sei riuscito a non
rimanere incastrato nel ruolo di
magistrato in realtà mi è dispiaciuto un
po negli angoli anche niente è tutto
chiuso
non faccio niente affrontare stiamo bene
attentamente sta andando nella direzione
giusta
non vedo niente qui non vedo nero
accordo produttivo come si faceva salire
la sopra
ho trovato c'è la ciotola e un colorante
come farò a salire la sopra o no non ci
provare i contatti non si sale mai dallo
scivolo
sapete perché non si sale maida nocivo
perché si scivola ci sono quasi non può
barare questo qui no non è banale fatto
sono sicuro perché ho trovato un altro
ingrediente
e qui la valentina paletta ma ecco che
cos'è questa questi sono dei pigmenti
che i g6 stata cattivissima perfida
siamo posizionati sullo scivolo
gli ingredienti sono qui dice allora
sono stato bravo anche come solo un
ingrediente li ho presi tutti per lenti
ma un omino dimenticato è no non mi dire
che di rovo lassù perché io non ce la
faccio a risalire la sua età le scappa
dove sarà sarà qui in mezzo a queste
palline
io provo a cercare
tu ha omesso creando quindi qui non mi
sembra dove la risposta che andando
quindi a pagina che soprattutto non c'è
non è guardato bene la farina medicali e
poi già controllato lino bravo
ora posso fare anch'io il mio slide
adesso tutti gli ingredienti gli
ingredienti cominciamo subito con la
colla cattivissima e perfida come così
vivi sibelco loro però che questo qui
allora mettiamo un pochettino di bonato
poi la soluzione per lenti e mi chiamo
il tutto alla soluzione per lenti e
adesso siamo subito pronti a fare lo
slide nati vivi di riferimento
probabilmente trovato io non ho trovato
niente io ho trovato da una ciotola non
c'era il film mentre chi è cattiva
questa è la mettiamo pochissimo ok è un
marrone è un burrone a bruto e un bronzo
marcolino perché la connettività con
quella quanto è uscito bello
nonostante il tuo pigmento brutto color
bruzzo votate uscito un bellissimo dice
vitale perché allora stai in più bello
votate 6 vinto e vinci evitare lasciate
un mi piace se volete vedere altri
challans e così è stato super divertente
ringraziamo ancora da party al cavallino
lo trova via circonvallazione 56 e ora
vi lasciamo a quattro case lille esprit
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione ciao
[Musica]